ja ja ja ja es auch hart ins gericht
hallo ich bin als ob wieder am hacken
ist wieder am hacken ist unter fragt was
war das gerade das was man isst mit dem
los weil es mit dem alle ganz schwerer
behinderung also eher kleine hexe weil
ich nicht so
ich esse textes
ich halte das ging
soll ja geil auf jeden fall vielen dank
und ich hoffe sie laden
ganz langsam ganz ruhig kam
wir wollen nicht wehtun wird zeigen wie
man schwimmt er jetzt alles klar
das reicht schon ich glaube schon ja
wird jedoch tiefer
das heißt auf jeden fall ja ok
aber was
bis dahin hatte geliftet alter daran
ich sagte ihm das zweite knappste
entscheidung meines lebens er macht
vielleicht ja vielleicht ja ja ja ja ja
ja nein nein nein nein nein